also a uh one-off oh no we're not going
to talk you through the rest of that
package instead we've got something even
better for you we can take you to our
deputy political editor sam coats who is
in westminster for it even better than
that i think you've got some breaking
news for us uh sam coats
that's right sam uh the prime minister
and the chancellor wanted you to be
talking about those cost of living
measures and the prime minister in that
uh little interview there made
absolutely clear he had nothing further
to say about the sugray report
but tory mps do so breaking news in the
last few minutes a government aide paul
holmes has resigned over the party gate
affair he is the eastleigh mp a new mp
elected in 2019 there he is on the
screen he was the uh what's known as uh
uh basically an aide to pretty patel he
has today quit and given this damning
statement
um he said that he would always uh he
was always planning to make a statement
following the publication the sue grey
report
and here uh on his website
you can see uh what he thinks he said
that uh he believes that revelations
from the sugar report that staff and
cleaners were not treated properly is
both disappointing and unacceptable
it's right that the prime minister
apologized to staff uh it clearly shows
the culture in number 10 that was
distasteful he goes on to say it is
clear to me that a deep mistrust in both
the government and the conservative
party has been created by these events
something that pains me personally as
someone who always tries to represent
eastleigh with integrity this distress
has led me to include that i want to
continue to focus solely on my efforts
being a member of parliament and
campaigns that are important to you in
other words that level of mistrust that
he now feels that there is in government
means that he feels he can no longer
stay as an aide to pretty patel an aide
in the home office so he has quit that
government job it's the most junior uh
rung on the ladder of government but
nevertheless striking uh it's also
unpaid i have ought to be said but
nevertheless uh as a symbolic act of
disgust in what went on uh he's today
announced that he's quitting government
now he doesn't say uh in his blog post
that's just gone on on his personal
website he doesn't say whether he's
submitted a letter to graham brady uh
and of course if you get to 46 uh lev
4056 letters then 54 letters then you
will uh face the boris johnson will face
a vote of no confidence we are at about
20 mps currently calling for boris
johnson uh to stand down uh paul holmes
says he's not going to say anything more
about whether he submitted a letter to
grand brady or not or give any
interviews or add in any way to the
statement that he's just put up on his
website but there is no doubt that there
is a sense that although there hasn't
been an avalanche of people calling for
boris johnson to go since wednesday sue
grey report there has been a drip drip
drip of criticism uh and of people
coming out saying that he should go uh
this is uh i believe the fifth person uh
since wednesday uh to either resign or
call for him directly to go uh so uh it
doesn't appear as boris johnson would
have wanted that ever that the sugray
report and yesterday's massive 21
billion pound package of help has
completely draw a line under it uh mps
still deciding uh to make public their
frustrations their outrage their disgust
and their dismay at what happens over
those months
in 2020 and 2021 where there were
parties at the heart of whitehall at the
height of the pandemic